[Applause]
[Music]
australia is one of the richest
countries in the world
in fact before the pandemic they could
boast of not having suffered any
economic crisis
however can you name any australian
companies think about it we are talking
about the country of the future
[Music]
just take a look at cities like
melbourne or sydney to imagine what the
world might be like in 2050. no matter
which ranking we look at australia is
always the top australians enjoy the
second highest minimum wage on the
planet at almost 2
400 us dollars per month they also have
one of the most freest economies in the
world where it's easy to do business
but at the same time it has an enviable
welfare state when the whole world was
suffering from the great recession the
australian economy was growing at two
percent
even now with the coronavirus crisis
australia can boast of being in a much
better situation than
any other country
in a nutshell australia is a rich
country very rich
however i come back to the same question
do you know any australian companies
possibly not many you may be familiar
with airline qantas
rip curl clothing brand is also
australian and if there are any fellow
youtubers around you might know another
one rode microphones for example the
microphone i'm speaking into right now
is from this brand and yes those
microphones are australian in any case
we are talking about relatively small
companies where is the australian google
or bmw
[Music]
so today's question is where does
australia's impressive wealth come from
what do they sell to the world that
makes them so rich
today we're going to answer all these
questions but first let's look at some
history
[Music]
land of opportunities in 1788 as far as
the outside world was concerned
australia was nothing more than a
british penal colony that is it was the
place where the united kingdom sent its
prisoners that's right for modern
australia
to become one of the richest countries
in the world the business acumen of a
number of go-getters was essential the
first of our protagonists is john
mcarthur a british military officer who
bought spanish mourinho sheep to
australia and founded a wool empire this
is how it all began in australia
something that was immortalized
with the following sentence
[Music]
australia road to prosperity on the
sheep's back a sentence which quite
frankly has led to the nasty spreading
of rumors about the mating habits of
australia's rural farmers but since then
australia has remained the world's
leading wool producer and mr macarthur
has been immortalized on the country's
banknotes
what is clear is there was more than
enough room in australia to have a large
flock of sheep but history has also been
a great ally of australian wool
great britain bought all australian
production during the second world war
and during the korean war prices
skyrocketed due to the american demand
for will to clothe their troops times
change
and so did buyers
price in australia climbs as china
demand rebounds
bloomberg but hold on a minute because
australia does not live on wool alone in
the middle of the 19th century a gold
rush broke out in australia to rival
those experienced in other countries
since then australia is still the main
goal producer in the world but it
doesn't end with just gold
in fact australia has everything iron
coal aluminium copper uranium and of
course
natural gas and oil really it's easier
to list what australia doesn't have like
reasonable accents
if we add to this the fact that they are
right next to asia we have the whole
picture who provides the natural
resources for all this growth in china
and southeast asia exactly
australia and that's why australia is so
rich and that brings us to the end of
the video right so
i'll see you guys later please subscribe
and don't forget to like us
obviously no we haven't finished yet how
could we give such a simple answer if
you really are followers of
visualpolitik those who never miss a
video because you have clicked on the
little bell when subscribing you already
know that having natural resources means
nothing if having natural resources were
synonymous with being rich argentina
would be switzerland and switzerland
would be argentina in fact we actually
talk a lot about the curse
of natural resources so the question is
how has australia avoided this curse of
natural resources but we're going to
take a look at that
right now
[Music]
old riches new techniques having natural
resources is not always good news
if it were africa would be the richest
continent in the world when a country
discovers natural resources one of two
things usually happens
first the congo scenario they have huge
tantalum reserves and guerrilla groups
form and kill each other to exploit it
and two
the venezuela scenario they have oil
they base their entire economy on
exploiting it and are ruined when the
market price of a barrel falls causing
the country to sink into misery
australia though they chose another path
[Music]
australians have always had natural
resources but the real australian mining
boom
came 40 years ago at that time australia
already had democratic transparent and
free institutions after all they had
copied the uk model and why is this so
important that all this was so
because australia provided the perfect
testing ground for the future
bhp plots massive automation rollout
across
australia australia mining
mining robots rio tinto doubles down on
autonomous drilling mining technology
and
for any australians watching we and
britain would like that model back it's
not really working for us at the moment
in other words australia's mining sector
is nothing like the classic miner who
has a pickaxe and a shovel on the
contrary with institutions that allow
for business creation and competition
australian mining companies have
had to rely on innovation today mining
is one of the most technological sectors
in existence
companies like bhp and rio tinto are
like the apple of natural resources so
australia doesn't just export
natural resources it also exports
technology this explains why many
australian companies exploit the
resources of other countries
london divests ecuador's largest gold
mine to australian miner latin lawyer
thanks to everything that we are telling
you it seems like australia has
now worries might specifically more than
50 years ago the then prime minister of
australia gave us a preview of what the
country would be like
[Music]
this australia of ours is a vast island
continent inhabited largely by people of
british or other european stock and with
the heritage of
national freedom personal liberty and
the institutions of a british
parliamentary democracy but
geographically we are part of asia
and increasingly we have become aware of
our involvement in the affairs of asia
harold holt
and yes being close to asia has been
crucial to australia's economy iron has
overtaken wool as australia's top export
product thanks to demand from chinese
steel mills so just as arab countries
struck gold with the oil price boom
australia has benefited from asia's
economic growth in recent decades
[Music]
to give you an idea australia consumes
barely 15
of its own coal production and its coal
production isn't exactly small 8
of that produced worldwide making it the
largest producer after china indonesia
and the united states so it sells the
rest
making australia the world's largest
exporter with a market share of 27
japan and china alone by more than half
of australia's coal
[Music]
but wait just a minute because all this
cool data has been really good for
australia
well not been so good for the planet you
have to look at what's happened with the
liquefied natural gas boom we've already
told you a few times here on
visualpolitik about lng
natural gas can be transported in two
ways by pipeline miles and miles of it
to carry natural gas or as lng where you
cool the gas to a liquid state put it in
tankers and send it to the
re-gasification plant at your point of
destination
well china's economic awakening and
japan's nuclear shutdown have boosted
demand for gas in
asia and who was around to take
advantage of it indeed australia and its
gas reserves now that they're very large
barely one percent of what's currently
estimated to be on the planet
to give you an idea qatar has 10 times
as much gas however australia is now the
world's
second largest gas exporter even so its
reserves are enough for australia's gas
production to have tripled
in the last 10 years going from being
the 18th largest gas producing country
in the world to being the seventh
largest producer in the world so
australia is one step closer to joining
the champions league of gas producers
and since it only consumes a third of
the gas it produces what do you think it
does with the other two thirds
well effectively they cool it down and
then the methane tanker sails to asia so
as you can see
australia has plenty of reasons for
optimism and you will say but wait a
minute grant what you're describing is
an economy very dependent on natural
resources at visualpolitik you
always tell us that this is a problem is
australia really the exception well no
it's not now let's look at the darker
side of the australian economy
the dutch disease if discovering natural
resources usually leads to a
proliferation of corrupt rulers we can
learn from australia that even if you
have good rulers
sooner or later problems will appear
fundamentally because if all you have to
do to make a fortune is take a shovel
and dig
because in australia you always find
something it is clear that there is no
incentive to develop industries other
than mining but wait a minute because
there is something
even worse than that there are problems
that are like an infection that spreads
throughout the economy we are talking
about the so-called dutch disease what
does this consist of
no it's not driving a bike whilst under
the influence of marijuana it is
basically the same thing that happened
to the netherlands when they discovered
gas fields in the 1970s let me give you
an example suddenly a country discovers
huge quantities of a resource let's say
it's australian iron and you have so
much iron that you export it selling it
to other countries and companies but of
course what is the currency of
international trade
[Music]
the us dollar in other words australian
mining companies earn millions and
millions of us dollars but they have to
pay their taxes in australia with
australian dollars so what do they do
well they buy local currency in other
words they exchange their us dollars for
australian dollars and what does this
mean
well all of a sudden the demand for the
australian dollar skyrockets and what
happens when the demand for a currency
skyrockets well
its value goes up in other words instead
of devaluing the currency
is revalued check this chart down
[Music]
as you can see in the chart from 2000 to
2011 the australian dollar doubled in
value relative to the us dollar after
2011 the evaluation has leveled off
during the corona virus crisis the
aussie dollar has even fallen a little
bit so australians are finally starting
to experience some inflation
and now i know what you're thinking
you're thinking since when is it a bad
thing that your currency doesn't devalue
theoretically the best scenario for a
country would be to have a strong
currency in this way citizens do not
suffer inflation and can make long-term
investments in other words by having
such an expensive currency australians
have more purchasing power than those in
almost any other country an australian
can travel the world and everything will
seem cheap he or she can afford to buy
anything from abroad more easily than an
american or a european
right but having a currency that is
constantly revalued also has its
problems check this out
[Music]
holden closure australia's history of
car manufacturing comes to an
end abc first ford closed then toyota
and finally
holden and of course ford and toyota as
i'm sure you know are us and japanese
firms but holden
although it was part of general motors
is the quintessential australian car
brand and what's your favorite car
australia let me see that's football
meat pies kangaroos and holden cars huh
right
well you sure sound like australia to me
yeah well
it was because in february 2020 it
closed for good and what is so relevant
about the closure of car factories in
australia well it's basically a symbol
of the hardships the australian
manufacturing industry is going through
the dutch disease has made it lose
competitiveness on all sites with such
high salaries it is very difficult to
compete with foreign companies and you
will say all right grant if that were
true switzerland would have no companies
and yes you're right the problem is is
that switzerland has no mining resources
and this is where the dutch disease
comes in high wages make it only
profitable to create industries with
very high added value
but the people who could create those
industries are too busy working in the
ultra profitable world of mining in a
few years your entire economy depends on
your natural resources in other words
you just became
saudi arabia
[Music]
to give you an idea more than half of
australia's exports are natural
resources in fact there is a ranking in
which australia is on par with other
less exemplary countries such as burkina
faso and uganda the ranking of economic
complexity this ranking measures on one
hand the level of diversification of a
country and the differentiation of its
products
for example japan is the most complex
country in this index because japan
exports a lot of unique technological
products
sony television is a sony television
distinct from all other televisions
however a ton of iron is the same
everywhere and australia performs very
badly in this area so
does this mean that australia is on the
verge of becoming a new venezuela or
saudi arabia not at all for a start
australia has strong institutions in
place so that once mining is no longer
profitable other industries can emerge
in fact this is exactly what happened
in the netherlands
the netherlands is the country that gave
its name to the dutch disease however no
one can say that today they're an
economy that lacks diversity or that
they are in decline but that's not the
end of the story
unlike other countries australia has
politicians who know how to focus on the
short term and that explains campaigns
like this one there's one australian
city
that's growing faster than any other
its momentum is undeniable and it's
rapidly confirming itself
as the country's new business capital
that city
is melbourne this campaign in bloomberg
which as you know is one of the largest
media outlets in the finance field is
being promoted by the state of victoria
with its capital in melbourne
in general aussie politicians are moving
to diversifying the economy
they are trying to attract foreign
investment to help develop more
innovative sectors
vikgov bringing in high-tech companies
to invest in the state man monthly the
results of this type of campaign will be
reaped in the medium term and cannot yet
be evaluated what we do know is that a
series of young australian companies has
already begun to make their way in the
world of the digital economy in the land
of the kangaroos we are talking about
platforms for freelance workers like
freelancer or 99designs fintech
companies like
bank or advanced software like canva so
now the question is over to you
do you think that these efforts to
overcome the dutch disease will be
enough do you think that australia could
be the ideal place for starting a new
business
you can leave your answer in the
comments below in the meantime don't
forget that we release new videos every
week so subscribe to this channel so you
won't miss any of our updates if you
like this video please give a thumbs up
and we'll see you next time
take it easy and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there